hi everybody thanks for um thanks for
coming my name is Marcos I'll be talking
about python web applications and how
making them is easy um my background is
in astronomy um but now I work as a data
science manager at Carmax where I do
pricing algorithms but I will not be
talking about space or price car prices
today but I'm making p p python web apps
and by making a python web application
and learning how to do it you can better
share your ideas your code and your
projects with a broad
audience so it's good to share your
ideas good to share your stuff um my
focus is really kind of on like maybe a
open research or a side project I'm not
really going to focus on kind of
deploying a big dashboard for your
company or a big production app uh but
just kind of the basics of how these web
application Frameworks work and how you
can use them to kind of uh uh you know
share your ideas with the world and I do
think that once you have learned these
tools or any of these tools you can
definitely apply it at your day job
that's how it happened with me I kind of
taught myself python Dash just for my
own edification and then I did end up
applying it end up using it at my job
after I kind of taught it to myself for
fun um so this is my hierarchy of
sharing it's not really a hierarchy um
but you you have some idea you found
something cool you just do nothing you
could just do nothing but maybe you like
crack the lottery or something you don't
want to tell people so that that's fine
you don't always want to tell everyone
everything um then you know maybe you've
got like a code snippet you know maybe
you have some cool function that does
some interesting data production you
could put that in a or a short blog
post um next thing you can imagine like
a GitHub repository where you you know
you people can clone it and play around
with the jupyter notebook or see your
data sets and such um above that again
this is more for code you could make an
installable package and put it up on
piie uh that would be good uh and then
kind of above that not really above it
now we're kind of getting into some
they're not necessarily hierarchy
anymore but for certain for certain
applications a static web app is a
perfectly good way to share your ideas
so we we just heard a bunch of talks
about Cordo in this room so great way to
to build maybe some interactive plots
but also kind of describe some
interesting um stuff that you found but
then somewhere at the top of this
hierarchy is the interactive web app
where you can really kind of go back and
forth the users can can interact with
your application um a web link has uh no
friction so uh one of the things I'm
going to show is this semantic Emoji
finder web web app that I built and it
started as a function that you would
just return a panda data frame but then
I built it out into a web app and when I
share shared this link with anyone they
can all kind of experience it without
Happ to install python without having to
be a data scientist they can just play
with it and it kind of broadens the
audience Beyond maybe just other data
scientists or other coders Etc um so
you're thinking well this sounds great
but um that sounds hard I don't know
JavaScript I don't know HTML well a web
application framework like the ones I'm
going to be talking about today um we do
most of this hard work for you right
they handle the server stuff they handle
the buttons they handle the
interactivity and you just get to write
Python and then the app kind of Springs
to life for you you don't have to write
other languages um you don't need to
know JavaScript CSS Etc um you can just
write python um other CSS won't hurt
we'll get to that but the point is that
scientists aren't web developers so you
can focus on writing Python and what
presumably you were comfortable
doing so these are the ones I'm going to
be talking about obviously this whole
session is about shiny uh so I will talk
about shiny for python at the end but
I'll also start off with a streamlet and
dash and then I'll kind of give an
overview of some non-enterprise
deployment options if you want to put
this these apps out into the world for
people to play with um so
uh this is the app we're going to be
building I needed a QR code for the end
of this talk because as you I think
people have seen it's very popular to
put QR codes at the end of a talk to
link out to stuff and I'll do that too U
but when I went to make one on the web I
got a lot of this I got a lot of please
log in please sign up to download the QR
code which I didn't really like so I was
like well I'll make one on my own my own
computer but then I thought wait this is
a great app I could take I could instead
of doing it in Python on my computer I
could make it into a little webout so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to uh make a demo app I made a
demo app of QR code generator we'll do
that three times in the three Frameworks
and then I will show but not show code
for that semantic Emoji search app that
I talked about just so you can see how I
implemented it three times that's too
more too much code to try and look at on
a screen but we'll um we'll look at that
too all right so streamlet is the first
one we'll talk about uh I think they
were bought by snowflake sometime in the
last year plus um you know they will
tell you that you take us you have a
python script you sprinkle in some
streamlet and then suddenly lo and
behold you have a you have a web app uh
simple things are simple in streamlet is
how I like to describe and so QR code
app very simple it's kind of like in
streams whale housee very easy to
implement um so you're going to see that
it's literally six lines of code to do
this in streamline right simple thing
simple um I've kind of diag GRA it out
here at the top we've got the Imports um
then we have an st. text input that's
going to be our variable that's going to
be set to the content variable and
that's just going to be the little you
know form on the page where you going
type in a string and then we're going to
check to see if that's you know truthy
uh and then we're going to use segno
which is a very nice library to make QR
codes it has no dependency so so that's
why I picked it um and that's going to
kind of create the QR code um object and
then create the the image data that we
need and we're going to pump that out of
the app into with st. image that'll
write the image to the screen so you can
see a screenshot there what it looks
like but we'll go ahead and run it um
and obviously Simple app simple
implication you know the perfect kind of
use case for streamlet and there you go
boom we have a QR code app um let's see
so now let's so the high level issue
with streamlet is it runs the entire
script like every time so for more
complicated apps and more complicated
interactivity that could become a
problem you might have two outputs you
might have a very expensive function
like a model run or something so you
have to cach that you have those are
considerations I don't typically run
into these when I the kind of apps that
I build with streamlet but it is
potentially a concern what I the issue I
ran into when I go when I going to show
you the um the uh Emoji search app is I
just wasn't really satisfied with the
look like the you know it works it's
it's you know I'm searching for launch
I'm getting a rocket like but the icons
are kind of small like I want want this
to be a table but it's really two
parallel columns cuz I couldn't get the
kind of tables I wanted out so it works
and it's it was the first this is
actually the first version of this app
that I wrote but it really wasn't kind
of satisfying like it wasn't really
scratching like my itch um uh uh and we
we mostly because of these layout issues
a lack of control a lot a little bit of
a lack of control or how how you lay it
out so let's um talk about plotly
Dash this is from um I said it's from
plotly who you may use their graphing
library and their plots are great um
it's based on flask and react if you are
a web developer you may have very strong
opinions about react um I am not and I I
don't but it is based on it is based on
react and flask one one interesting
thing about it there's no what's called
server state so like every time you
click a button in dash it's sending
everything from your browser to the
server and back which kind of makes it a
uh a little chatty sometimes if you're
sending a lot of stuff back and forth so
both Dash and shiny you explicitly
Define a layout so you saw on streamlet
there was no code saying what the
layout's going to look like right both
shiny and dashy to have to explicitly
put a du layout so that might be some
inputs like a text field which is what
we're going to have for the QR code app
but it could be a little pop-up menu it
could be like a date picker you know
there all kinds of different potential
inputs you could enter um then we're
going to have some kind of functions uh
in dash these are call back called
callbacks um and then we're going to
have outputs right so for the QR code
app just going to be an image but you
could imagine of course for more data
sciency app a graph a table maybe
multiple things like that one one
interesting thing about Dash is that it
does not distinguish between input
inputs and outputs so when you see the
layout on the next screen any of those
things that you will see could be an
input or an output because Dash can read
and write to both which is kind of neat
so here's the QR code app now I'm
implemented in dash I'm lay just showing
the layout I kind of skipped the Imports
uh just for um uh so I can fit all on
the screen so we're going to go through
these one line by line it's it's
definitely more verbose than streamlet
right stream it with six lines of code
here just my layout is 12 lines or
something so html. H1 just for and I
said you wouldn't need to know CSS
that's CSS right there when it says
style Tex line Center so that's just
making our headline then we've got a
little uh Dash bootstrap component uh if
you do make Dash apps I really recommend
using the dash bootstrap components
they're really useful um it makes things
a little prettier so I'm using an input
group to kind of group the button and
the text field together note that they
both have IDs right we have this keyword
argument ID equals content and ID equals
go we'll need those later when we want
to make this app do something um so we
have an input and a button and then
we're going to have our little our
little image uh div to kind of take the
data when the app does something right
again notice there's an ID ID equals
output image and then there's a little
CSS to style it to center it so that's
where the stuff's going to go so how do
we make it do something that's just a
layout it's not doing anything let's
make it do something that's with a dash
callback so we have this decorator in
front of the Callback function and this
is what kind of links all of those
elements to the the uh to you know to
the function so we can actually do
something to the app to the application
so the output we have every Dash call
can only have one output which is a some
of a limitation so there's an out that
might not be true anymore but most of
them have one output so that's obviously
going to be our image and we're going to
put into the SRC Source um uh field of
the image output which is where we want
our data to
go then uh we want the content of course
of the text field and we want the Go
Button to make this thing go uh but I
don't you notice that the second one is
State not input so that is telling Dash
don't react when the content value
changes right when you start typing
being into that field don't fire this
function off only fire this function off
when input is clicked so we get the
number of clicks at that go
button now the number of arguments in
the in this callback function has to
equal the number of inputs so we have
one for Content that'll be our content
variable our string and then the number
of clicks is just an integer that goes
up we don't really care what that number
is so we're going to throw it away and
not worry about it and assign it to the
underscore variable and then this code
should look familiar right same code we
saw in the Streamline app make the QR
code return the data and then this is
kind of boiler plate to make the app run
run in uh locally on your computer so
this is what the app looks like I think
it looks a little nicer we got some nice
you know nice little bootstrap button
there we got a nice little centered
everything I think it looks nice this
has been deployed I have a version of
this it has a little added a download
button so this is deployed on my website
there'll be a link to that later I think
this works pretty well let's look at the
complicated app write the Emoji search
again no code just looking at it this is
the canonical version of this app this
is the version that I like this is a
version that that I send people I've got
nice I've got a font nice font got these
settings the hideable settings where you
can Surface and priorities of search
results for like skin color or gender um
you can change there's actually a font
adjustment scale if you want more
results or you want more bigger font I
love this version this is the version I
send to people it works very well all
right now this is a shiny session so
it's probably a lot of people here know
more about
shiny than I do but let's go ahead and
look at shiny for Python and how I did
this and that app obviously shiny for
python was announced only a year ago so
it's very young um I did start in shiny
I built our shiny apps way back when
before I became mostly a python person
um so I was very excited when this was
announced and it was fun to play with it
and try and and do reimplement some of
the things that I built in other
Frameworks in shining for python so much
like Dash we're going to
explicitly lay out the UI right but of
course instead of using Dash functions
we're going to use shiny functions and
we're going to make a little page
wrapper um instead of a html. H1 we've
got a ui. panel title but the same idea
we're going to make a title I'm taking
advantage of this cool sidebar layout
that's built into shiny so we're going
to have uh the text field and the button
in a in a little small panel and then
the image in a in a right panel you
notice that there's also an ID keyword
argument right to identify the elements
so we have ID equals text and ID equals
go to label the input text and the go
button and then we're going to have a uh
output
UI uh with the ID QR code to hold the
image notice that unlike Dash the inputs
and outputs are explicit here right we
have the inputs all start with input
inut and the output start with output uh
because uh unlike Dash the you they're
kind of separated into two two classes
right um okay so unlike a callback shiny
has these shiny server functions so
instead of one long decorator we have
two short decorators so output tells it
tells the shiny server this is going to
make output and then render UI says the
kind of element it's creating you could
just be render do text for example if
you were just outputting text
um again we don't unlike shiny where we
have to kind of tell it in the in the
Callback sorry unlike Dash where we have
to tell it in the Callback what's an
input what's a state um shiny just kind
of figures it out based on what's in the
function so input. go is the variable is
this the button it's a number and then
input. text will be the string we want
to
convert but I only want it to fire off
when we hit input. go so I just kind I
kind of this throwaway function here to
make sure that this function will fire
off with the go button and then I
isolate the input. text field so when
input. text changes this app isn't this
the function doesn't keep running over
and over again every time you type a new
letter there's another way to do this
with a different callback but sorry with
a different decorator but I implemented
it this way anyway and the rest of this
looks familiar right this is the same
the same conditional the same stuff it
looks a little different the syntax but
we're making the QR code and we're
sending it out to the app right uh and
then this is more boiler plate just to
kind of create the um app uh in the
script so here is the shiny QR code
implemented once again now in shiny um
looks pretty nice I like the sidebar
layout I've Implement I've implemented a
version of this as well and put it on my
shiny server so if you want to make QR
codes with this app it's out there and I
will send a link show a link at the
end all right so here is semantic Emoji
search with shiny I did not try to
implement the settings for various
reasons that I can get into but I think
it looks nice I built this um this thing
at the bottom is a bootstrap table I
built a little function that I I linked
to there that is um turning a pandas
data frame into a bootstrap table and it
is also kind of passing in a special
function to to to customize that right
columns because obviously that right
column is not just a single text field
it's got a lot of stuff going on in it
so I made that customizable and so I
that's pretty um a little beta but it's
out there if people want to play with it
all right let's talk about deployment um
this is again non-enterprise deployment
um obviously there are a lot of
knowledgeable people here at this
conference to talk about Enterprise
deployment you know there's posit
connect which can actually deploy all
three of these things but let's just
talk about you as a hobbyist want to
deploy things I'm probably preaching to
the choir here but chiny has a lot of
ways to deploy small apps to Chinese
server which I have um installed on my
oops which I have installed on my web
server um it's free it's open source
does require you to have some kind of
cloud web server I have one myself but
you do have to understand that so not
necessarily super easy if you're not
familiar with setting up a web server
shiny app.io which I hadn't used until
this week very easy to use very easy to
deploy a small app on shiny app.io but
obviously if your app is really big or
really membering intensive uh you might
need to uh uh use a paid tier and then
sh live that iio also pretty new idea to
run some of these simpler apps in a
browser um which uh is another way to do
it streamlet has a something very
similar to shiny apps. I called
streamlet Community Cloud it kind of you
just point to a GitHub repository and
like it brings up a little stream app
but also you know limitations on how
much RAM that has and stuff so you can't
run a really big app that way um and and
limited by github's of file size limits
and then ironically I've I've deployed
probably seven to eight Dash apps on my
own website but I will cannot call it
particularly easy did write a whole blog
post about how I do it um it is a
standard what they call a wsgi python
application but it is not particularly
trival to to deploy you can also use
things like Heroku or python anywhere um
but happy to talk more about about
deployment uh deployment things if you
want and you know my would encourage you
to not really worry about deployment at
first just kind of play around with one
of these Frameworks play around with all
of them run them locally I think when I
first started using these at my day job
I was just running it locally and that
actually got a lot of value out of that
but you will get emotionally involved if
you start making these apps you will
like want it to run you want it to look
pretty you want it to look a certain way
and then you want to share with the
world so you will eventually probably
want to deploy it but there are there
are ways to do that um and I think
that's the end I want to thank thank all
of you want to thank uh people at my my
my manager at Carmax for helping me come
out here and I'm happy to take a few
questions and that is the QR code to my
my talk notes it's like a little blog
post I wrote it has links to all the
official documentation it has links to
all the demo repositories has links to
the live apps that I've deployed uh and
I'm on the Discord if people want to T
tag me uh in the python Channel or
anywhere else happy to and happy to take
a few questions if we have any we have
some questions for Marcos so for first
question is for app layouts in dash is
there a way to refactor the layout into
a class or functions to make it more
readable and modular I guess that's a
good question a lot of people when Dash
apps get more complicated they break it
out into a separate file and import it
into the main file so it doesn't pollute
like your one big file so um and you can
also break it out into sub you know not
function but have variables that's what
I usually do when I write a dash layout
I'll have like variable equals you know
this is the uh output page and I'll make
that a variable and this is the input
section I'll make that a variable and
that helps clean it up a little bit so
that it's a little easier to follow
instead of one big block of of nested
python lists and
stuff okay next question is what's the
best way for a python developer to learn
in CS CSS to be dangerous that is a
great question I I tend to steal other
people's CSS is usually my uh my advice
um so that every every one of these
Frameworks lets you sprinkle in CSS a
little differently Dash has these python
dictionaries that kind of match like the
the keywords I think shiny you put the
whole CSS string in there but um it is
yeah CSS is always an adventure I think
I'm trying to get I think one of these
things centered took me a lot longer
than it should have I'm always Googling
CSS so it is always a challenge I said
you get emotionally involved you're like
I want this to be centered and then you
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
the CSS to get it
centered okay let's let's thankful
Marcos for the great
[Applause]
talk